hey guys my name is Jess it is the 12th
of July today and here's the important
gaming news for you to see Microsoft
engineer Mike your bar has explained why
the company are creating projects
Scorpio which is slated to be a more
powerful console than the xbox one
Gabara told the Guardian that
Microsoft's efforts were inspired by the
smartphone business model explaining in
the phone market to people are more used
to upgrading fast and wanting the latest
of everything according to what they're
telling us the consumer expectation is
games and apps a better work even if i
upgrade while looking at the console
business and asking how do we provide
that choice to users it resonates with
them because other devices are doing
that microsoft said providing
compatibility between xbox one xbox one
s and projects copia was very important
to them microsoft studios GM Shannon
Loftus added that a number of developers
are already making games with Scorpio
support in mind given the power of the
upcoming console as for Sony they do
have a more powerful PlayStation 4 in
the works and possibly also a
slimmed-down ps4 there's a new overwatch
hero for you to dominate with or suck at
depending on your skill level and she's
actually related to one of the existing
heroes anna is a support character who
uses her biotic rifle and other
abilities to simultaneously heal her
teammate and hurt her foes and she's far
as mum they thought she was dead but
she's not isn't that nice for everybody
you can try out right now through over
watches public test realm on PC you like
she's equipped with both long-range
healing and poison MO as well as a sleep
dart which does precisely what it says
on the tin if you're stuck in close
quarters you can detonate a biotic
grenade which both wheels teammates and
damages opponents 10 minutes wait her
ultimate ability turns a teammate into
an unstoppable super soldier with a ton
of buffs and that one's not bad either
alongside the introduction of Anna comes
with patch bearing down
changes speaking of changes blues that
have decided that teams will now be
limited to just one of each character
over watches competitive play mode
lizard also plan to ditch sudden death
and allow matches to end without a win
or a loss but they are trying to
implement what sounds like some kind of
participation metal reward so players
don't feel like they wasted their time
finally today that Pokemon mobile game
that everybody's playing is making a
crap ton of money shocking I know
research company super data have
estimated the Pokemon go has made 14
million bucks since its launch in july
five most likely made in large part from
people like my friend who found
themselves out of pokeballs but
unwilling to let that dragonite get away
so the data has suggested that Pokemon
go could have problems keeping players
engaged to long-term as is the case with
most mobile titles the company explains
chances are we're looking at the mobile
games equivalent of a summer hit so
rather than a revolution in the mobile
game monarchy pokemon go is expected to
arrive in Europe of Japan and throughout
Asia within a few days developer niantic
have announced they intend to roll out a
trading system and improvements to AR
among other features do let me know what
you cared about today and stop by games
but we've got stories on Blizzard
silencing world of warcraft jerks and
amazon prime day deals and see you
tomorrow